so we can actually uh
annotate them based on the phenotypical
characters and and
so that uh
they separate very well or we can at
least understand uh do they separate
very well according to phenotypical
characters or different uh sample
characteristics that we associate from
the uh for the data etc so before that
we can also enable
loadings
which will tell you what are the
important dimensions or what are the
significant dimensions
that are that are
that contribute the most to separate the
samples into these multiple groups we
observe that there are versus there are
some some groups that we can observe in
these samples
and if you enable loading we can see
that there are some specific genes it's
like
this
1 6 0 1 8 0 and
0 6 5
6 1 8 and
we can understand that
these genes are these transcripts are
responsible for
isolating the samples to this group and
while these genes are responsible for
isolating the samples to this group and
and and so hence we can gain more
information not
how or where the samples are grouped but
also what are the most informative genes
in our dimensions are in our input
so we can expand the principle component
analysis not only to two dimension but
also to three dimension in some of the
cases that will be very helpful like how
you interacted with the interactive 3d
plot
that i just demonstrated you and in
addition to that as i mentioned
when you have annotation available or
when you have the sample characteristics
available for your input table we can
load those sample characteristics also
into a separate object and we can use
those sample characteristics to color
the samples and color their distribution
in the principal component analysis
output so that we can understand whether
the pca's variance explained actually
separates the samples according to the
different characteristics that we
associate the samples with
we can extract these sample
characteristics from biological
condition under which the samples are
measured are different phenotypical
characteristics of the sample as such
for example if it's a gene expression
data from a tumor sample then we can
take whether these samples are from
what subtypes of tumor or whether these
samples are from tumor samples or
adjacent normal samples
and any other layer of
molecular characterization or
histological characterization has been
performed on these samples and whether
we can associate that to this sample or
you can explore little bit beyond those
molecular characterization of the
samples to the clinical characteristics
of the sample like um
like the demographical distribution
like age group like ethnicity whether
they are
actually represented in the gene
expression data distribution of our
analysis right
so how do we do that so we actually now
again
go through some of the important
codes that we already
had some introduction to so we load the
packages some of the
gg45 is one of the package that will and
let us use auto plot functions that we
have discussing so far
and in this read.table function as i had
told you we specify the
location of the sample here and then we
specify some of the characteristics that
is associated with the sample like the
separator like whether or not the first
row mentions the header and then we can
add some associated options which will
help us organize the data
like how characters to be interpreted
and whether or not do we have to check
for duplicate row names and messages
so
if you load this data and then if you
check first few lines of the data we can
quickly find out that
the first column is
okay
the first column will actually give you
uh the annotation of the sample
and we can extract only the numerical
component of the sample by selectively
uh
by selecting those specific numbers of
columns that we want to extract and then
we can apply principal component
analysis only on the numerical component
of this column and if you do not do that
then this analysis is going to throw you
an error that we have a non-numerical
character or non-numerical counterpart
input in your
data and here we enable scaling
to be true and
immediately again we can use some basic
functionality like auto plot to plot it
and in the auto plot function as i was
mentioning
in the above section we can
specify or we can actually
include the annotation or sample
characteristics that is associated with
each and every sample
we can color the sample according to
their
annotation that we have included in the
input table so in this case we are going
to plot the principal component analysis
result using auto plot function and as
and we are going to
mention where this annotation is coming
from it is coming from the data table
data and
the column that gives you the annotation
is group and when we do that we can
immediately see that the samples are
color and
and
our analysis of this input data
is reveals that we have a very good
separation of different
sample types like the normal like
luminal and all the four subtypes of
this tumor they are very well separated
as you can see and um
and that is very good very nice to know
and we also
find out that the principal component
analysis actually covers quite a bit of
our very good range or explains a very
good percentage of variance in the first
two principal component themselves like
the principle component 1 explains 50
percentage of the variance that
you find in the original data and
together they
explain something around 68 percentage
of them
and in addition to that again we see
that we can actually um
[Music]
label them
and this okay we can actually label them
according to the sample size sample type
and
we can also uh
okay we can label them according to the
sample types and uh this label has to be
sample types there is some error then i
will check to take care of that so once
you learn
uh about how you can perform different
principle component analysis and
how various
different visualization options will
help you understand the output of this
analysis and
you can fine tune the output or
fine-tune the visualization for your
need for your necessary maybe you need
only up to this point or maybe you need
to
include the sample types or sample
labels uh along with this output so you
can do that
with the given options that is available
so once you have learned this code so
the next
area or the next section in this lesson
will help you practice all the codes
that you have learned in this practice
and learn the output section so in here
we give you a
a console which is an r console by
itself and we include the codes that you
have just learnt in the previous
sections and we first give you the codes
as such and explain it to you that you
can simply run this code and
you are expected to
understand or you are expected to see
some of the answers or some of the
plots that is associated with this code
that we have
seen that it can produce in the learn
the code section so i simply run this
code
and see whether it runs or not
yes i see that the output tells the
success in running the code the answer
is correct and i produce
several plots and i also produce an
output of
my principal component analysis
variance
and
i can open these
files and see
whether the output that i created
agrees or
goes very well or describes how it is be
described in the
learn the code section because we are
using the same
input data
you can check that yes okay it does very
good so uh now you can start exploring
different parts of this code and
start fine tuning and start changing
some of the parts of this code so that
you can
expand your understanding of the code
that you have learned so far and some of
the hints that we have given here for
example if you see
in this
area where we are calculating the
principal component analysis uh we again
have not used the option to scale or to
center the data so we can actually do
that and some of the example codes are
given here so you can try scaling and
centering the data you can now modify
this by including scale dot equals true
and center
equals true
and then if i run the code okay i click
i can clear the console and the outputs
by uh clearing it
and then if i
put
it clear
if i run the code okay
okay now i have changed something in the
data so this checks for the
pre-calculated data so by centering and
scaling some of the outputs have
actually changed but
that's okay that's why that's why my
pop-up said success in running the code
which is what my aim is but the answer
is incorrect because this code block is
intended to produce some other answer so
now i can actually uh
check whether or not i see a difference
if i perform scaling and centering in my
original data
yeah in the principal component analysis
if you have saved this one then you can
easily check
and you can again come down
and see how you can write the output
right i just showed you from the server
how you can access the principal
component analysis that is calculated
for your input file and you can save it
as a table
you can use the table for further
downstream analysis like clustering and
other methods so this
code block actually tells you how to
save the table right and the necessary
piece of code or focused piece of code
is actually given here where you can
find out how to write an output from our
synthetic into a file
and again we have to tell what to write
or what object to write out and what is
a file name and some associated
characters how this file name has to be
or how this file has to be created by
like do we have to include column names
do we have to include the row names or
how two columns have to be separated
just like how you have described the
data while loading in the data
so let's run this and
see
for ourselves
yes in addition to couple of plots i can
also see there's a table that is
produced and you can open this table and
you can download this table save it as
download this table and find out uh
about this
principal component analysis calculated
for your input file so let's time
constrain let's not do that i will let
you explore that you can download this
table load up in excel and then explore
this table further
and then
after that what we have actually done is
now you get a now you got a good hang of
how the
lesson works and how you learnt the code
on how you can
access or how you can use the r console
to run these codes and even modify these
codes to suit your necessary suit your
requirements and now in this section we
have deleted some of the syntaxes to
keep you interesting and then you have
to find out where we have deleted the
syntax and complete the code there to
run this code successfully so if you run
it as such it's going to throw you an
error and error running the code and
most of the time like in any programming
language
the error message that r is going to
give you is going to be very difficult
to understand so we clear this and then
we can go through this
code line by line if you had understood
or you can also refer to what we have
done here and what we have given here
and
find where the
necessary
completion is required for this and i
see
okay i see that the principal component
analysis function is not given in
in its full form and i also see that
there is a problem in in plotting the
principle component now it's completed
pca risk
and i can also see that
you have to run it time and again and
and see if this produces any error or if
it's not producing any error now i have
rectified some of the portions and there
are some more portions that i need to
find out where the header is and one of
the areas where the error is it's here
and i have to mention uh which
column corresponds to
coloring or annotation in the data
expression table that that is group and
if you can know that if you open it in
in another file or in another tab you
will know that and let's see what else
do we have
and we can actually see here okay in
this plot uh we have to mention and we
have to enable label
and in this plot we can mention we have
to
disable framing
and okay once you do that
we can again
try running the code
okay this time i made all the necessary
changes and uh
i get success in running the code and
the answer is correct and i create a lot
of plots which
is very
what all the plots that we have actually
explored and
that will help us understand the
patterns in this data so
after this after
letting you complete the code and we
give you an assignment where again
some of the parts are missing and you
can again
explain or try
running this so i give you this as a
challenge so today you can try
completing this one assignment and let
us know by an email or yeah
by email if you can successfully finish
this uh option or not and for those who
can who wants to know more or who wants
to explore little bit further then what
we have done so far we have more options
where
we have another input table
my computer is frozen
yes we have another option for another
input table which will help you
understand
the um
power of principal component analysis in
identifying outliers so you can go
beyond the basics here
where
you can you will get a taste of what i
have demonstrated you in the server you
take the output of the principal
component analysis and then apply k
means clustering to this to the table to
identify the different types of clusters
or different number of clusters that
your
principle or your
data contains of your k-means plus
string identifies in your data table